biden's disastrous exit from afghanistan
was on display for the world to see and
both our allies and enemies were
watching we took orders from the taliban
handed over our military equipment and
lost 13 american lives the biden
administration was incompetent and weak
and north korea was noticing turns out
they've been doing some military work
behind the scenes according to a report
by the united nations nuclear watchdog
agency north korea has resumed deeply
troubling work on its nuclear reactor
looks like kim jong-un is no longer
listening to joe biden or he is
listening and likes what he hears
joining me now new york post columnist
miranda devine miranda i put out a tweet
when all of this kind of exploded noting
that americans should beware and there
will be more terrorism there'll be more
violence and they should look for
adventurism by our enemies this is a
perfect example
what is your take on this what are they
doing
isn't it just tammy this is just a
little taste of what's to come in the
next you know three and a third years of
the biden presidency to come and
the debacle with the withdrawal from
afghanistan has just put up in neon
lights the weakness uh the fecklessness
and the incompetence of this president
and his administration um unfortunately
there are all sorts of unforeseen
circumstances around the corner all we
know is that america's enemies have been
waiting for this moment of weakness to
pounce and they will in every which way
and unfortunately you know tonight um
what what should have been a a you know
a good moment of leaving and ending that
war in afghanistan which most americans
wanted was so botched uh it's done more
harm than good and you know i can't
believe that joe biden has let anthony
blink and the secretary of state
address the american people instead of
the president doing it
but when he does do it tomorrow he
better not try a victory lap because
this has been a debacle in every way and
you know the massacres from from the
taliban are only just beginning they
have 85 billion dollars worth of our
sophisticated technology and helicopters
and equipment including seven thousand
of those biometric scanners they've
already been going door to door in in
pursuit of collaborators with america
the torments to come and joe biden told
us just two weeks less than two weeks
ago ten days ago in that george
stephanopoulos interview that he would
not be leaving until he had every
american he didn't do that anthony
blinken is trying to hose that down and
say the united nations has just issued a
very sternly worded resolution that's
just delusional this is not the way
islamist fundamentalists you know this
is they should know that yeah this is in
listening to him it was like someone who
had been living in a cave somewhere and
had no idea of what had transpired over
the last 30 years when it came to
terrorism a very strange attitude of
contempt in a way for the american
people and at the same time you know
we've we've got this framework now with
afghanistan now we're going to do a
diplomacy from qatar uh and and all of
that
it's it's as though they expect to just
kind of walk away from this is that but
this is going to we're less than two
weeks away from the september 11th
anniversary and they did this this is
the irony of what you know about how
horrible this his position is now that
this was really meant i contend and i
think a few others do because they
wanted a photo op for september 11th and
this is what resulted
well that is exactly the words that
kathy mccollum used the mother of 20
year old marine uh riley mccollum she
said you know my son died so that you
could have joe biden a september 11
photo op and you know it's hard to
escape um that conclusion because this
is a white house that is driven by
optics number one and the the
entire premise of this withdrawal was
not to do it in a safe and orderly way
it was to get out so that he would have
a big trophy to brandish on september 11
and we should not allow him to do that's
right well a great uh great uh uh take
on all of this and thank you for your
perspective you've been in the midst of
everything that's been happening uh here
in new york and in the world as well of
course miranda devine thank you very
much hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else